let's see here let's go to the three
zero one area code who's calling from
three zero one can you hear me
yes I can hey David this is derek from
the great state of Maryland how are you
good thank you
quite an a predicament and I would like
to get your opinion about something okay
okay so a little bit about me I am 24
years old and I am in a relationship and
I recently found out that my girlfriend
is a part of a Facebook group and I'm
not really sure what to do and she's
been really bugging me out so I'm just
wondering like if you were in that
position what would you do if I was in
your position now let me ask you this is
this the first time you became aware
that she's Pro Trump became aware of it
and before when whenever I began
bringing our politics with her she would
just sort of brush off so I had no idea
what a politics or how long have you
been dating here hold on you've been
dating someone for a year and you and
you the topic of what her politics are
have never been broached try to bring it
out then she would just ignore it or
brush it off so I never really knew who
I was she thought of issues didn't that
strike you as people didn't that's oh
okay so hold on she said she was a
political or she wouldn't answer the
combination of both concern emphasis she
would just sort of just not answer at
all she would be brushed off but other
times I thought asking her about her she
would say she's not really interested in
how old is she she is 23 mm and how did
you meet online dating okay and are
you're not a trump supporter I take it
well you're not you know I'm struggling
with how could you date someone for a
year and not know their politics because
very often it comes out in other ways
even if she's not answering overtly
political questions you know if you walk
by a homeless
person for example often times
particularly in a relationship that's
been going on for a year
there would be some comment made that
would either be an empathetic comment
which would imply someone on the left or
it would be like a why can't these
people just get a job which would
suggest that they're on the right I'm
having a little bit of a hard time
wondering what you've been doing for the
year that you didn't figure out what her
politics are and then how did you find
out she's in a pro Trump group on
Facebook he left her phone and I just
got curious and I decided to scroll
through and I discovered the group and
she was part of it mhm and are you have
you met her family their family she has
actually been trying to avoid that from
happening so now that I'm looking back
at it I think I should have noticed all
those red flags I think I think you're
right you are she did not want me to
meet them I think that my simple probing
questions have had the effect of getting
you to the answers that you're looking
for I'm pretty pretty crazy man yeah
yeah yeah yeah anything else today all
right very good okay thank you for the
call